Direct stake asks,
how do you see love arrows
in your general world view?
We're just love to come see you guys.
See asking possibly hard questions.
Well I think that truth has to be embodied
inside love or embedded inside love.
You know,
it's not easy to figure out a hierarchy
and failures of ultimate values.
There was great,
the great traditional values of the
good and the beautiful and the true,
let's say the courageous
and that sort of thing.
It's not easy to figure out how
you arrange those hierarchically,
but it seems to me that truth is likely
something that serves a master of one
form or another,
at least ethical truth.
And love is something like the decision
that being is fundamentally good or it's
the decision to act as if
being is fundamentally good.
That might be the right
way of thinking about it.
So you know,
I thought about this in relationship
to my son when he was little,
three years old and like unbearably cute.
And you know what?
Three year olds,
they're,
they're fairly easily hurt.
I mean they're quite robust in some ways,
but they're fairly easily hurt.
They can run out into
traffic and you know,
they skinned their knees and
they bang heads on tables,
you know,
they're prone to emotional breakdown and
they have all these extreme fragility.
Is that make you nervous?
I would say,
and alert and attentive as an adult.
But that also expose you directly to the,
to the fact of the
potential tragedy of life.
I'm not sure as,
I think one of the reasons why
having children matures you in,
in a way that nothing else can.
And you know,
I imagined,
I've written about this in my new book,
12 rules for life.
I imagined that I could remove his
vulnerabilities one by one so that he
couldn't be hurt.
And so,
you know,
I thought,
well,
I could make them into a robot.
It was 15 feet tall and
made out of metal and,
and that would remove his physical
vulnerability to have tremendous strength.
And you know,
you could turn them into something
like a superhero with all these,
with all these strengths instead of
these exceptional vulnerabilities.
But what I realized very rapidly
was that every time you removed a
vulnerability,
you removed and essential
part of the person,
right.
A part that you really love because
with a little three year old boy kid for
example,
mean it's there,
it's there,
it's their fragility.
In some sense that's a huge
part of their charm and appeal.
It's not like you'd wish it on them,
but it's,
it's part of their,
it's part of their value as being,
and I think that reflects
something like the,
this paradoxical situation that the
Dow was referred to win when they,
in the Dell teaching,
they talk about the what makes a plot
valuable is the empty space inside it.
It's,
it's what,
it's not as much as what it is that makes
it well actual first of all real but
also useful.
And there's something really profound
about that in the limitations.
I would say limitation is
the precondition for being,
and it's really,
I,
I'd like to get this rate so that
you can follow it because it's,
it's one of the most useful thoughts
I think that has ever occurred to me.
The first is that
limits are a precondition for being
just like rules are preconditioned for a
game.
Like you can't play a game where
you can make any move at any time.
You have to narrow the playing
field's substantially and you have put
restrictions on what can be done
in order for anything to be done.
And so maybe being is this
paradoxical state where there's,
there's just enough limitation
to maximize possibility,
something like that.
And that seems right to
me why that would be.
I have no idea.
But maybe that's something
like an answer to why,
why there's anything,
what,
why anything was created or I know
I'm speaking metaphysically but,
but I still think it's worthwhile
doing so and then well if,
if,
if limitation is the precondition for
being then then that that introduced the
suffering into the world and tragedy
because of course suffering and tragedy or
consequence of limitation.
And so then the situation is that
if you want to have the being where
possibility is maximized,
you have to accept the
limitations that produce tragedy.
And so that's maybe the
justification for tragedy.
Assuming that such a thing
needs to be justified.
And then the final thought in
that three part series as well,
maybe there's a way to live so that
the tragedy that's an intrinsic part of
limited being becomes bearable or
becomes even something like celebrate a
bubble.
And I guess that would be akin to niches.
Um,
wish for the eternal return,
like he thought you should live so
that if every moment that you lived re
recurred eternally,
that that would be a good thing.
And so it's a heroic motive being,
it's conceivable that a heroic mode
of being that requires the adoption of
responsibility gives your life sufficient
gravitas and weight and meaning.
So that the tragedy of being can be
withstood without becoming corrupt.
And I would certainly hope
that that would be the case.
And I think there's some reasons
to assume that it might be.